we ready to go I guess no one's telling
me know so I will hello everybody I'm
mark Kamla time provost and executive
vice president here at Carnegie Mellon
and on behalf of the entire Carnegie
Mellon community I'd like to welcome you
here and I'd like to make special thanks
and welcome to Governor Rendell
congressman Doyle and to welcome both of
them back to Carnegie Mellon introduce
our lead guests here in just a second
but before I do I'd like to say that
Carnegie Mellon is honored to host this
event it's particularly fitting that
we're gathered here in the gates center
this building was dedicated last fall
the primary donors the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation it's dedicated to
cutting-edge research and education that
we hope will inspire ideas and jpop
brighter future today's event is a
celebration of an unprecedented
commitment to connect americans to
opportunities for jobs education and an
improved quality of life carnegie mellon
is proud of its historic role in shaping
advances in communication technology
dating to our successful efforts to
create the first wired campus a quaint
concept at the time over a quarter of a
century ago the researchers who engage
in that pioneering effort could only
have dreamed of the far-reaching vision
and promise that underlies today's
announcement now I'm particularly
pleased to have the honor of introducing
our special guest today secretary Gary
Locke president Obama has brought to the
Department of Commerce a tireless
advocate for US companies and workers
they are the same traits that enabled
then-governor lock to turn the state of
Washington into a jobs and technology
leader in his leading role in advancing
the president's economic agenda
secretary Locke has brought a vision for
not merely the recovery
of the US economy before its rebirth a
rebirth fueled by innovations that
expand economic opportunities from urban
neighborhoods to rural communities it's
my pleasure and please join me in
welcoming secretary Gary Locke well
thank you Mark for the introduction it's
really a pleasure to be here at carnagie
make a melon and to be here at the Bill
of Melinda Gates a computer center bill
and melinda gates are from my home state
of Washington actually dear friends it's
great to see that their legacy is
throughout the United States of America
and that it's fitting that we're here as
Provost camludt said to be talking about
communications and the power of the
internet here in this particular
building and its really great to be here
joined by a great friend of mine a
governor rendell who has just been one
of America's most powerful advocates
forceful advocates in terms of economic
development but also focusing especially
on education and focusing on rebuilding
our infrastructure and I think the
projects that we're about to announce
today go hand-in-hand with both economic
development rebuilding our
infrastructure and educating the people
of our of our country also pleasure to
be here with the congressman mike doyle
who supported the Recovery Act to be
sure that we can create economic
opportunities like these not just here
in Pennsylvania but throughout the
United States of America so congressman
Doyle thank you very much for your great
to support also want to acknowledge the
great support of senators Bob Casey and
Arlen Specter who voted for the Recovery
Act and without their votes along with
the congressman Doyle's this grant and
all that it promises for Pennsylvania
simply would not be possible we need to
understand that this these two projects
that we announced today were made
possible by the Recovery Act and the
courageous votes of individuals like
congressman Doyle and Senator Specter
and Casey these are tough times for the
people of America and certainly for
Pennsylvania economists say that the
recession is over that there are all
these leading economic indicators
pointing upward but the reality is that
there's still millions of Americans and
millions here in Pennsylvania that are
out of work and President Obama and his
entire administration are of one mind no
matter what the economic indicators say
this country is not in an economic
recovery until every American who wants
a job has one and today I'm proud to
make an announcement that represents
another small but important step in
providing economic hope and opportunity
for the people of America and certainly
here in Pennsylvania we're here to
announce two investments that will bring
high-speed Internet access to nearly
three million households and some
400,000 businesses here in Pennsylvania
while linking up thousands of community
anchor institutions like schools
hospitals libraries and public safety
offices to the information superhighway
this investment is being funded by the
Recovery Act which the President signed
into law just a year ago to put people
back to work immediately but also to lay
the groundwork for long-term sustainable
economic growth the Recovery Act has
already brought substantial benefits to
the people of Pennsylvania there are
some five million working families
receiving two and a half billion dollars
in the middle class tax cut tax relief
some too there are some 2.6 million
seniors veterans and disabled receiving
who have received a 250 dollar economic
relief payment there are displaced
workers received an extra 2.6 billion
dollars in extended and expanded
unemployment insurance and of course
great funds came to the state of
Pennsylvania for things like 351
transportation projects valued at over
one and a half a billion dollars but
also included in that recovery act with
some seven billion dollars to expand
high-speed Internet access to
underserved communities and unserved
communities all across the mayor
including rural America because of the
dedicated efforts of leaders from the
Keystone initiative for network based
education and research as well as the
governor's office we're here to announce
today some almost 130 million dollars to
help Pennsylvania expand its high-speed
internet capability this is critically
important for Pennsylvania where some
thirty five percent of all households do
not have access to high-speed internet
connections and today when you don't
have regular access to the high-speed
Internet you don't have access to all
the educational employment and even
business opportunities that the
high-speed Internet provides the funding
that we're announcing today will help
fix this glaring inequality in
Pennsylvania the first grant is
allocating almost a hundred million
dollars just a couple hundred thousand
dollars short of a hundred million
dollars to fund the Pennsylvania
research and education network project
this project which is the result of
collaboration between Pennsylvania's
leading universities health care
providers libraries and other
communicate other community
organizations will lay nearly 1,700
miles worth of fiber-optic cables to
expand high-speed Internet access it
will directly connect 60 critical
community anchor institutions like
universities k through 12 schools public
libraries and medical facilities in 39
counties across south and central
pennsylvania and this network will
become the main artery of healthcare
information across the state by linking
the hospital and healthcare services of
association of pennsylvania the
university of pittsburgh medical center
Penn State Hershey Medical Center the
Pennsylvania a health initiative and the
mountain Health Care Alliance this 1700
miles worth of fiber-optic cables is
really going to be comprised of two
rings like an interstate beltway and
like a major highway with connecting
local roads this high-speed Internet
highway will enable the private sector
to branch off and bring
high-speed Internet service to two
million households and some 200,000
businesses in Pennsylvania the second
grant that were announcing today will
allocate over 28 million dollars to the
enhancing connectivity in northern
Pennsylvania project this project will
lay some 649 miles of high-speed
fiber-optic cables as well as build out
612 miles of fixed wireless links this
will ultimately serve 32 counties in the
mountainous terrain north of Interstate
80 including the cities of Titusville du
Bois Scranton and wilkes-barre because
of this investment the private sector is
expected to hook into the state Internet
highway and provide high-speed internet
service to a million households over
200,000 businesses and some 2,600 anchor
institutions in addition this project is
going to make state government services
more accessible or more easily
accessible to rural and low-income
residents all across the region these
new grants coming to Pennsylvania will
pay dividends for years and years to
come not only do they bring economic
opportunity to the beneficiaries to the
medical institutions to the hospitals to
the universities to the government
facilities the libraries and schools but
as I said the private sector will be
expected and is interested in then
building off or branching off from this
highway and providing direct internet
service to homes and businesses that
means businesses will be able to sell
more of their products and services not
just within Pennsylvania but all around
the world so I want to congratulate
everyone here today who helped put
together a very excellent proposal in a
very competitive process to bring this
important investment to the people and
to the state of Pennsylvania we had some
1,800 applications asking for some 19
billion dollars in funds out of a pot of
only 1.3 billion dollars so for
Pennsylvania to have roughly 100
30 million dollars in round one out of
over a billion dollars in available
funds really speaks to the high quality
of the proposal the reach that these
proposals have in terms of the people
and the businesses the institutions the
proposal will serve and certainly to the
leadership of the governor's office and
his team as well as the the consortium
of institutions and community
organizations that have put this a
proposal together so congratulations you
have done a really outstanding job now
it's my pleasure to turn it over to a
great introduce you there you go out you
know uh you know I've known ed for such
a long time and I keep remarking about
his incredibly slim and fit stature so
when you look around you're always used
to looking for a more imposing figure
but but but clearly governor Rendell has
been incredible leader among the
nation's governors and in all of our
meetings he's always talked about
investment investment investment
creating jobs jobs jobs but also making
sure that the jobs are in industries of
the future so that we have long-term
sustainable economic growth and
opportunities for people and he's always
focused on jobs but he's also known that
you have to create the jobs in areas
where you need them and in industries of
the future especially in in technology
and in communications but you also need
to make sure that you're investing in
the education of people and this
high-speed internet middle mile project
that Pennsylvania is receiving will
certainly enable more students and
businesses to use this information
superhighway to advance their dreams and
their goals and so you owe a lot to
governor ed rendell it's my pleasure to
turn over to a good friend
good morning everyone up it's a pleasure
to be here with secretary Locke we
served together with as mayor's when he
was mayor of Seattle and I was mayor of
Philadelphia he preceded me to the
governor's chair in Washington did a
great job both in Seattle in Washington
and is doing a great job as Commerce
Secretary so mr. secretary we thank you
for being here and we thank you for
choosing Pennsylvania for these two very
very important grants you know people
are always asking me and this is part of
the whole national debate is the
stimulus working and the answer is in
Pennsylvania for sure a resounding yes
yesterday I was on a bridge in central
Pennsylvania talking about our
infrastructure programs Pennsylvania's
already has received over as the
secretary said nearly two billion
dollars in infrastructure for our roads
or bridges our highways or water and
wastewater systems or mass transit
systems and I'm proud to say that we're
number one in the country in bridges
roads and highways in money that is
currently being spent we lead the nation
and the ability to get that money out
and have it spent and creating jobs
quickly it's been a tremendous plus but
like all stimulus projects it addresses
a real need it is in make work we have
the largest number of structurally
deficient bridges of any state in the
country and this is helping us cut into
that backlog dramatically it provides a
substantive benefit but it also creates
jobs congressman Doyle said to me well
the secretary is speaking can you
imagine the number of jobs that are
going to be created laying almost 3,000
miles of broadband and think about that
not only are there a lot of jobs are
going to be created but they're good
jobs that are going to be created today
in pittsburgh i'm here to tap three
stimulus programs we're doing three
separate events this event which is a
job creator and provides a tremendous
subset of benefit to us secondly i'm in
the carnegie the city of carnegie to
tout the weatherization program which
was slow to get started because of our
budget stalemate in pennsylvania but now
is underway there
are in allegheny green in Washington
counties we've got 500 homes currently
being weatherized we're going to do 30
thousand homes over the next 18 months
in Pennsylvania creating a thousand jobs
and and a lot of substantive benefit to
those families who will be able to cut
their yearly energy bills dramatically
because of the weatherization efforts
and then I'm going to be in Aliquippa to
talk about the housing tax credit the
eight thousand dollar tax credit for
first time home buyers that's allowed us
to not only allowed a lot of people have
my houses but as allowed new home
building to start up again in
Pennsylvania has allowed even when the
money is used to buy an existing home it
is allowed remodeling our orders to
start so each and every one of these
programs is aimed at a very important
substantive benefit but is also creating
literally thousands of jobs as we go
secretary Locke talked about the money
that Pennsylvania has gotten directly
for its own budget we've gotten 2.7
billion dollars that's in this year's
budget if you were to remove that 27 2.7
from a twenty seven point eight billion
dollar budget give you an idea of just
what that would mean i would have to lay
off if i did it just with state workers
thirty-seven thousand workers almost
half of our state workforce if we did it
as a mix it would mean tens of thousands
of county workers teachers policemen
firemen emergency service employees all
of whom would have had to be laid off so
when the president says we've created or
saved two million jobs you can bet that
that's accurate you can bet the tech
accurate common sense tells you subtract
two point seven billion dollars from our
budget we're not going to raise taxes to
fill that void because you can't raise
taxes in the middle of a recession we're
not going to be able to cut our programs
to the bone people are complaining all
over the state that we've already done
that and they're not incorrect we've
done what we had to do but think of what
the loss of 2.7 billion dollars
would have been in employment it would
have been dramatic now to speak to these
two grants secretary Locke is exactly
right they hit at infrastructure they're
going to help rebuild the infrastructure
of this state boom because broadband
like the electrical electricity grid are
important part of infrastructure they're
not often thought of as infrastructure
but they're very much as much of a part
of our infrastructure as roads bridges
highways and water and wastewater
systems are so they're going to rebuild
our infrastructure but both of these
grants are going to able our kids to
have a better education which will allow
them to compete in the high tech global
economy we've made tremendous progress
as Secretary Locke said by investing in
our kids education we're now the number
one state in the Union in in achievement
on achievement gains on the national
test we're the only state that had
significant gains in every subject
matter tested at every grade level
tested think about that for Pennsylvania
to lead the nation in education
improvement no one would have ever
thought that's possible but we've got to
keep it going and these grants today the
second grant the Keystone project red is
AK through 20 grant it's not just for
higher at it's not just for hospitals it
goes all the way down to kindergarten
it'll let our kids and libraries and in
schools get access to the Internet as
quickly and as broadly as they can the
second grant the middle mile project
that secretary Locke talked about is
very important as most of you know
pennsylvania passed the
telecommunications actor actually
reauthorized our telecommunications act
in 2004 and it gave the
telecommunications companies to mandate
that by 2015 they had to wire everyone
in pennsylvania they had to have
broadband access to every home in
Pennsylvania that has been a slow task
because there's no economic incentive
for the telecommunications companies to
go into low density populations where
there are challenges or topography the
mountainous areas of Pennsylvania make
it difficult the infrastructure in some
cases is there and the low density
populations don't make it fiscally
lucrative so we have had the state has
worked hard
to incentivize the program by
aggregating demand a grade and demand
and as a result getting coverage from
the companies and our program has been
pretty successful I think right now we
have a aggregated demand in 207
community service areas that broadband
has been deployed because we were able
to successfully aggregate demand and 174
more of these community service areas
are in progress are being set up this
ARRA money is going to be
extraordinarily helpful in allowing us
to build out to the rest of Pennsylvania
and his secretary Locke said their 32
counties mostly in the northern tier
mostly between i-80 and the New York
Pennsylvania border the where service is
not uniform and where we need to step
this up the good news is that we can
build on assets we already have the
ridge administrate administration
started and we've been following up the
build-out of our public safety radio
network so we have towers place that we
own the state owns in ninety five
percent of the area of the state and I
think that was a big factor in us
getting this grant money because of the
existence of those towers and we're
going to use those towers we are shovel
ready we are ready to go the middle mile
project is ready to go because the
existence of those towers and work can
begin almost immediately so this is a
great announcement for Pennsylvania a
great announcement for Pennsylvania's
children a great announcement for all of
the people who don't have access and you
know in the digital economy if you don't
have access to broadband it's like you
don't exist and we want every square
mile of Pennsylvania and every
Pennsylvanian to have this access now I
want to introduce a congressman Doyle
and as secretary Locke said thank him he
not only was a vote for the Recovery Act
he was a strong driving proponent and
it's fitting that he's here to help in
the announcement of these grants he
voted for it he was four he's not like
many members of Congress who opposed it
who trash it at every chance they get on
television or on k
the talk radio shows and then show up at
the grant announcements taking credit
for the grants Congress and Doyle was a
true supporter he I think was essential
to getting the votes necessary to get it
passed he's been a real leader and
everything then affects western
Pennsylvania and I'm proud to have work
with him for seven years and look
forward to doing it one more year
congressman well thank you governor and
Secretary welcome to Pittsburgh you can
come as many times as you like when you
have announcements like this to make
it's good also i see representatives
here from Senator Specter and Senator
Kasey's office and it's it's nice to see
votes translate in the programs that are
going to help Pennsylvanians and this is
this is a great program the broadband
technology opportunities program or be
top is one of the parts of the stimulus
bill that I'm most proud of you know
when you think about connecting people
in both unserved rural areas and
underserved urban communities like mine
to the internet this is one of the best
things that the Recovery Act does to
stimulate new job growth and better
economic opportunities after all
everybody knows it's nearly impossible
to apply for a job these days without
internet access and computer skills and
I'm especially happy that the Department
of Commerce selected this application it
was a real team effort many of us in the
Pennsylvania delegation pushed hard for
this project and I'm glad to see it
funded penryn will mean more jobs and
better education because federal
recovery act money will build this
infrastructure for Pennsylvania and it
will make the internet access available
and more affordable to consumers and
small businesses across the state now
penryn is mostly focused on helping
rural parts of our state but it has
benefits for Pittsburgh to first the
network was designed with the help of
the Pittsburgh supercomputing Center and
CMU and pitt face three rocks that three
rivers optical exchange and their
expertise is critical to build and
maintain it second Carnegie Mellon and
Pitt educators researchers and scholars
will be coming up with the ideas the
programs the websites and the
applications that will run on the
network they'll be teaching the distance
education they'll come up with the bold
new ideas that need the speed that this
network will have UPMC doctors will be
able to reach more patients in
communities far outside Allegheny County
without leaving their office and
internet startups across Pittsburgh and
large companies with offices here are
racing to come up with their own ideas
for websites and applications that will
reach the people that pen Ren will
connect it's a good day for Pittsburgh
mr. secretary I look forward to your
next trip here and future announcement
there's this is the first round of
funding and we intend to compete with
the rest of the country for more of
these dollars and you can expect some
pretty competitive proposals in the
second round thank you very much the
congressman the governor and I are
available for any questions from the
press at this point also want to
recognize seated in the front row as
Larry Strickland who's the head of the
National Telecommunications Information
Administration that oversees these
entire be top program and whose staff is
just an incredible job in a very short
period of time fielding some several
thousand applications again asking for
19 billion dollars of funds out of a pot
in this first round of over a billion
dollars just a little over a billion
dollars so thank you very much Larry
great any questions any questions who
will be responsible for selecting
various vendors and those people that we
install his projects at state agencies
somewhere else well we provided the
funds to the state agency and the
consortium and then it will be up to I
think the state well it governor rendell
talk about exactly how the private side
will be engaged in providing that last
hookup from our highway what we call a
middle highway to actual homes of that
last mile that last hookup it will go
through the state and it'll be a
public-private partnership again using
public assets we've got those radio
towers for the public safety radio
network all over the state so we'll work
with the providers using those assets
using their own skills and we'll get
this done but I can't tell you how
important this is I think we'll be able
to be totally wired as a state by the
end of next year for sure and that's way
ahead of schedule that's a full three
years ahead of schedule it's very very
important people just can't compete
economically small businesses can't
compete if they can't do this and again
the educational benefits are awesome as
you know I've spent 220 million dollars
of state budget over the last four years
on classrooms of the future putting
laptops in every high school classroom
in our four core subjects in every at
one of our school districts in
Pennsylvania and that's revolutionized
high school teachers parents the kids
themselves tell us how different the
classes are how the kids are exhilarated
coming into class how they focus the
teachers are learning how to use the
smart boards and we're we're in the 21st
century and we're cooking in high school
but we've got to get internet access
everywhere they're starting with the
kindergarten and this is going to help
us do it so it's a great great program
last mile is importance of people
well again that's what you get from
aggregating demand and with the stimulus
money the upfront costs are going to be
significantly lower so I think it will
be affordable and again it's our job to
aggregate demand and make it work but
it's also the telecommunications
companies mandate that was what they got
when Act 70 was reauthorized in in
return for some other benefits so it
will be affordable we just again if you
look at the topography of Pennsylvania
you can see how difficult a task this is
and when you take that topography with
low population density that exists in
many parts of those 32 counties this is
a struggle but this money is going to
help make it possible it is another job
that are included in the only number i
I'm we were just talking as the
Secretary was speaking when you think
about how many miles of fiber optics is
going to be laid across the state i I
mean there's going to have to be gearing
up for that and I think it's going to
mean a lot of jobs in not just in laying
the pipe but all the other suppliers and
networks to i don't i don't know that i
could put a number on it but it's going
to be substantial yeah I'll take a shot
and say that for 18 to 24 month period
it will employ over a thousand people
but I think Congress maduro made a very
good point and I'm trying to make the
same point yesterday when we did our
road bridge announcements you can't just
think of the jobs created on site the
people are actually doing the physical
work of laying the cable all over
Pennsylvania you have to think about the
jobs created back in the factories
because cable gets produced steel for a
rhodes asphalt concrete aggregate for
roads they get produced and most of us
going to be produced in pennsylvania
factories and we did the press
conference at a bridge yesterday and the
one of the contractors told us that they
recalled some 38 people just to do the
work on this 12 million dollar bridge
recall people who they had laid off when
the recession hit so when you talk about
jobs in it by the way Thea
mama administration's been very
conservative on their job estimates that
they report to the people they don't
count the indirect jobs I actually think
that's foolish they should count the
indirect jobs because that's a as
congressman dorset its jobs laying the
cable but it's also jobs producing the
fiber and all the things that go into it
governor released by the White House
yesterday from the Council of Economic
Advisers said that 84,000 job or saved
or created in Pennsylvania name is an
accurate yeah absolutely again go back
and take it and mike wants to comment on
this too and probably the secretary go
back and just take what i said it moved
into a nasty of the 37,000 state workers
who would have been laid off with it
included in that probably not at that
level they probably included somewhere
between fifteen and twenty thousand jobs
so again it was very conservative but i
can show you program after program the
job creation in october we took a
flashpoint in october there were eleven
thousand jobs people working on road
bridge and highway construction that
doesn't even count water wastewater mass
transit projects etc and we surveyed all
the vendors and had produced material
for those jobs and another 2,500 jobs
have been created in most cases recall
jobs but some new jobs so that was just
thirteen fourteen thousand from one part
of the program so i think when you say
you say that you're pretty much spot on
but i also think you've got to realize
that the stimulus did more than just
that type of job creation the stimulus
put over ten billion dollars or will put
into the pockets of pennsylvania's
secretary Locke outlined some of that
the tax cut money the money for
increased unemployment compensation the
extra food stamps money and what de
pennsylvanians do with that money will
food stands money and the unemployment
comp they buy food they buy clothing who
do they buy it from they buy it from
small businesses and that means the
small business doesn't have to lay off
people or maybe hires people back to the
added demand that eight hundred dollar
tax credit you know a lot of that also
went into buying essentials to keep
families of float so
there's an indirect job production that
isn't in that figure that's why the
people who are criticizing the stimulus
either are doing it for purely political
reasons or don't use common sense don't
use common sense if we give people more
money for food stamps what are they
going to do it spend it to buy food it
goes into the economy it helps the mom
and pop stores stay open at a time like
this so if anybody sits down and uses
their common sense they will see that
the stimulus works gosh january 2009 the
country lost 750,000 jobs in november we
actually gained jobs in january of 2010
we lost 20,000 jobs it's not an accident
the gdp was down six points in the first
quarter of the last quarter of 2008 in
the last quarter of 2009 it was up five
point seven percent the biggest increase
in six years that's not an accident
those things didn't happen in a vacuum
there are 55,000 stimulus projects
nationally underway they created a whole
boatload of direct and indirect jobs mr.
secretary will these two announcements
have any bearing on reviewing
applications for the vid program for the
witch programmer that brought me in for
the be top of the second round no will
be will be looking at all of the
proposals again there'll be a little bit
more money probably about three billion
dollars available for the next round or
a little bit less than three billion for
the next second round we do have a
requirement that every state receive at
least one grant be awarded one grant and
it could be you know for computing
center of a couple million dollars all
the way up to big projects like we just
announced today so again it's going to
be very very very competitive our
criteria are a little bit sharper a
little bit more focused or definitely
emphasizing what we call these middle
mile highways of high-speed Internet
connecting up community organizations
hospitals community colleges educational
institutions government to facilities
creating almost like beltway's rings
or interstates and from which the
private sector will then be able to
connect and just like we have here in
Pennsylvania so there's no rule that
says that once if you received a grant
in the first round you're ineligible for
a second grant from the second round let
me just also say that a lot of these
projects because of these projects were
able to bring high-speed Internet access
to communities that otherwise would have
to wait a long long time or possibly go
without high-speed internet access in
our lifetimes especially in the rural
parts of Pennsylvania and all across
America for a private sector company to
spend the millions and millions of
dollars laying fibre-optic for just a
few homes or dozens of homes doesn't
make economic sense but by the
government working with the government
here in Pennsylvania providing and
building out that that highway then it's
a lot cheaper and a lot faster and a lot
easier for the private sector to then
build out these little Spurs from our
super highway to individual homes and
businesses and there are a lot of jobs
associated with laying the fiber optic
cable putting in telephone poles if it's
not being buried in the ground creating
a lot of jobs there but there are also a
lot of jobs available and economic
opportunities for the people who receive
that high-speed Internet access whether
it's that motel or that resort in
Pennsylvania that is then able to
advertise its its services and its
products worldwide that creates jobs
that creates economic growth in come to
these businesses and when businesses
have more income they hire more people
they expand their workforce they provide
better wages for their employees so
those are the benefits economic benefits
long-term economic benefits to the
people and the businesses of
Pennsylvania in addition to just the
immediate work of laying the fiber-optic
installing the wireless devices on these
towers throughout northern Pennsylvania
thank you very much